So after years and years of build up all the hype has finally come to this
The Avengers there has never been a movie quite like this done before.
Six previous films staring individual superheros were all coming together for one event
that was planed from the very beginning.
Though you could look them as individual stories they were all leading up to one grand event.
This was the event.
Now don't get me wrong there were crossovers before but nothing like this and nothing this well thought out.
So there was a little bit of a concern
would it pay off? This would definitely have a good opening weekend no matter what it's been built up so much.
But would it be the gigantic hit everybody wanted? Would it be as good as the other Marvel movies?
Or as promised even better 10x better something specularly huge?
Well the short answer is yes.
Not only was this film a mega mega mega mega hit but both critics and audiences alike agree it was a ton of fun and worth the wait.
The movie centers around the return of the sinister Loki
He apparently is in cahoots with an evil force in space who wants to, what else takeover the world. Of course.
He plans to do so by using a magic scepter to hypnotize people
and a gigantic alien army to open up a dimension and bring him into our world enslaving mankind.
Who can stop him The Avengers of course.
Most of them just coming off of hit movies.
Iron Man, Captain America, Thor and even The Hulk played this time by Mark Ruffalo.
But also included are characters we haven't seen that much of Black Widow and Hawkeye.
And the film literally from this point on is nothing but one liners and action.
And I know it sounds strange but it's actually kind of perfect.
When you see these characters together a lot of them with big personalities just having coming off of big movies what do you wanna see?
You wanna see them interact.
That includes working off of each other, talking to each other, getting in fights, throwing insults.
And because these actors and characters are so strong and so defined it really works.
The whole movie can be all of them just stuck in a room shooting the shit and you know what it'd be ok.
Their that interesting and that much fun to watch.
But of course thats not what people are paying to see. Their paying to see action
and when the action gets going it's some of the most fun I've seen an audience have in a movie theater.
Every superhero has a unique way of fighting a villain.
And each one has a different personality trait to make it interesting.
Well for the most part we really don't know Hawkeye yet but eh were not at Avengers 2 yet give it time.
A lot of these movies as I mentioned before deliver a lot of character but sometimes skimp a little bit on the action particularly in the climax.
The great thing about this movie is it makes you think it's about to end.
They do the team shoot you think alright well their just gonna punch out a few more and then were gonna stop.
But nope it's just beginning.
They spend a lot of time fighting creatures in the city and unlike Transformers you don't get tired of it.
It gives you the exact amount you want to see.
Every superhero does what you want to see the superheros do.
The Hulk jumps around and smashes things. He punches this giant whale I don't know what is
Captain America throwing his shield, Iron Man flying around shooting stuff
even Black Widow who we didn't see much before this movie suddenly becomes this really cool character.
She actually might be my favorite out of all of them.
And yeah I'm waiting for that damn movie too.
The one element of the film that is kinda lazy is the story but to it's credit story is not what you wanna focus on here.
This is the first time you've seen all these characters come together and you just want to see them be those characters and beat shit up.
So the story the story is very minimal. Hell it doesn't even really make that much sense.
Loki wants to get all The Avengers together knowing they won't get along and that
would somehow destroy them.
Ok?
Well as Tony Stark himself said not a great plan.
The who story is kinda like that there's all these weird little convinces that don't really add up
and are kinda confusing but really you don't care.
You're there to see The Avengers fly around and be The Avengers and this movie gives you that in bucket loads.
They have been hyping this thing up forever. One of the biggest Marvel teams of all time actually comes to the big screen and it delivers.
Does it have that much drama? No.
Is there that much thinking in it? Absolutely not.
But it's just an incredibly fun dumb summer film.
This is the kind of movie you kind of want to see kind of mindless.
You want to want to see a lot of dumb explosions.
But it's done with so much wit and humor that you find yourself enjoying even the silliest moments.
It's nice to see a cinematic gamble like this pay off and for the right reasons.
If we just stated off with this movie before Iron Man, Captain America and all the other films
it wouldn't be as good. It'd be impressive but
it'd just be to jumble because you wouldn't have all the characters to find.
Well now that we do know all these characters and we enjoy them
and they've certainly proven themselves to be entertaining.
They come together beautifully.
I even kinda find myself enjoying Mark Ruffalo as The Hulk
I'll admit I like Edward Norton just a little bit more because I think he's such an engaging actor
but I like the take he does.
He plays it as a guy whose been spending years trying to achieve inner calm
so he kind of looks half awake sometimes.
But its actually intentional .
It doesn't seem lazy at all it seems like a guy trying to keep his rage under control
because he knows what will happen with it.
And so sacrifices some of his stronger emotions to keep everything balanced.
It would have been cool to see Norton but this guy is a good replacement.
What else can I say it's The Avengers one of the highest grossing films of all time
one of the most hyped up films of all time
and it gave you exactly what you wanted.
It's silly, it's funny, it's over the top. It's a comic book movie.
At no part in it can you say it's not a comic book movie it just drenches itself in it.
And after years and years these were seen as embarrassing films to make
Now they completely won us over.
And everybody is trying to do exactly what The Avengers have did.
Create a movie universe, something that can continue
and all these other characters can interact with each other
and come in and different ideas.
They can all try it and some even succeed
but none of us will forget who did it first.
Why? Because it was just so damn fun.